this is a production of cornell
university
it's a really great honor
to
give talk at
your
department to make myself more likely
visiting your
campus actually i have a background
there's a cornell background
i always miss
that landscape a lot
uh i
received my phd in the circus
uh some many years ago so i visited
recycle for a couple times it's a really
beautiful campus
so
today i will
talking
a little bit about our effort in the
biosphere about chemical circuit study
and how does the boston
low plays alone in the
global carbon
and other gas greenhouse gas
budget
all right
okay
so this let's start with a very basic so
that's a ghg problem uh if you look at
the atmosphere
chemistry composition
the greenhouse gas actually barely tiny
percentage less than one percent
but this
house has become problem uh is a big
because
uh that's a
since
uh pre-industrial like 1750 is from ipcc
recently report that increases
largely increased
c2 uh already increasing 47
nothing
increase at 156 percent and and to own
increase 23
this
large increase
uh recently ipcc uh
ar6 reporters yoda
if you look at the this left
this
gray color that's mean the temperature
changes since pre-industrial that about
increases 1.1
degrees c
if we separate the attribute this
increase into
a different
components like a greenhouse gas
increase or
like a aerosol
cooling effect
and the greenhouse gases we can further
break it down into co2 methane and
natural oxide in the right side you can
see that greenhouse gas
emission already
causes 1.5 degree
increase
so that's the the level of a paris
agreement uh uh we tried we tried to
reach
but uh uh
there's a also called a cooling effect
so net uh increased about the 1.1 degree
so let's just uh think about this
global carbon budget we
have a three
story to prove the atmosphere land and
ocean
they foster view this uh
isoprogenity phosphorylation
release annually about a 9.4 per gram of
carbon per year
during the recent decade
and
the land use change uh most
tropical deforestation uh emitted like
1.6
or this mistake it should be 0.7 plus
minus
they annually accumulate the atmosphere
about 5.1 pentagon carbon per year and
the ocean
is thinking about the 2.5
so this is about 23 percent of the
esophogenic emission and the land
atlantis think uh for a long time we
have larger uncertainty about
the ipcc
line this thing is about 3.4
plus minus uh
0.9 paragraph compensation which is
about
31
of an isophogenic emission
so the
land thing has become very important so
the land thinking
geopolitic politics
so the question here is that where this
covers things
located which part
in the
u.s china or other place
and how large
so there's become not science and also
there's a
geopoliticals
so about
30 years ago the very famous paper uh
leaded by pence
they have this condorcet
hemisphere middle additive cover think
hypothesis
because a large carbon source from
topics uh
uh particularly
tropical deforestation then you need a
larger carbon
uptake by middle attitude so that's use
soon
uh
the atomos sphere inversion uh modeling
to
uh determine the location the first
very critical and very influential paper
and
today
because the liner covers thinking
because so important
for kilometer
changing negotiation
so that's become very political
there's a one paper just
published last year so a large chinese
common thing uh land encompassing they
based on the top down estimator that
which is uh
atmospheric envision
they also use a geochem global 3d
chemistry a transport model many people
you know this your chem
to ask the meat chinese land the basket
to think that about
1.11 pentagon carbon per year during
2010 to 2016. what
what does this mean doesn't mean
equivalent about a 45 annual
uh chinese anthropogenic initiative over
there
so about a little bit less half of uh
chinese as opportunity mission as a
appetite by chinese landing system
then
that's
about the 33 or one third of the global
understanding is allocated internal life
so that's a become very
uh
surprise very surprised
but this is actually not
new uh about
uh
this is uh
many years ago uh that's grouper and uh
princeton and noah
and
there
hasn't been a large and also american
thinking and the most located 15 degree
north a source so which is america
uh
us
so the unsupported emission during the
same time periods
emission like a 1.5 pentagon carbon
uh so
as the opportunity is co2 emissions less
than
land cover sync so
u.s don't need a
mitigated cop uh
first viewing machine
so this
also
a top down estimator so
i mean uh to people who don't know the
top down estimate but there's a really
base the mass balance
uh atom of spin number emission number
for security release number then you
have they also have their ocean
uh
uh uptick uh sink then you can determine
uh the biosphere
think they use
this spatial
model that located
where this cover located but don't give
you
a
mechanism
what cost
what is the underlying
mechanism
to con
leaders success how to learn the cover
sync
but
later they use the top board up
inventory based approach they now uh
there's a
new estimate as about north americans
about 0.3 to 0.5 per gram carbon uh
more based on this
forest inventory and also price-based
ecosystem model
and russia
also
just published the paper this year so a
russian scientist said that russia
foreign
operating much larger than large carbon
uh there is a
47 percent higher than deporting the
national greenhouse gas inventory
so that's
today
uh other country
uh also wanted to find a large cover
thing
uh for their own land
uh that all this different country uh
uh there's a common thing added together
it's a much much larger than global
currency
but how can we as a scientist
to believe this
number
uh particularly we need a given
uh
explanation and
uh what's the underlying mechanism to
lead the cover sync
so the biosphere uh it's a dilemma
they are not only
hepatic carbon solar photosynthesis
but the biosphere also
releases carbon dioxide into atoms
through this
decompositions
plantar respiration and also
soil respiration
more than that
biosphere also
emitted other two major greenhouse gases
why the
methane
another one is
natural oxide
so
if we wanted to
evaluate
or
give more accurate estimate about sphere
rule in
the globe by uh gorbachev actually that
we need to consider all of this
and if we think about this
human population growth the biosphere
actually the effect could
but everywhere is discovered by human uh
you know this
population grows
for the first 1 billion increase taking
123 years but for the more recently
they won
billion increase only taking about 11
uh that's data 1998
but this
human population increase
they need food
they need
water they need
other
for survival for living
so the first
human
need is a food
so
that's the global
cropland
expansion
you
the long history deconstructed by uh
hardi
you can see that in the
uh
long in the today
the
north american
asian
india china and european and south
america a large portion of this land the
club
but if we go back to the pre-industry
the club line it's very
uh
with crop refraction that's very small
uh think about it 1700
north american even
a little bit uh crocodile right
we only have like a stream
uh
for decatur history yeah
nasa make him
and uh
not only landing expansion collaborative
expansion but also other material
imported into the
land
lacking
fertilizer use
adamantius and nitrogen deposition
menu production they largely increased
in the
last
150 year plus and then if you look at
especially
large portions this is a nitrogen
imported into
asia region north america and also
europe
but even we think about it here
uh
globally uh
globally uh civil club production the
aid has a
lenient increase right
but if
this
uh
closely associated with a
uh nitrogen
phosphorus
uh
imported into the club land and also
water fresh water import that's like
irrigation
but if we uh calculated naturally use
efficiency you can see that
from 1960 to the 1980s largely decreased
and now it's more stable so energy
use efficiency is very very
long the information is efficiently very
low where's the nitrogen
going
one the nitrogen will go to water
leaching
nitro loaded into the water where
polluted the water
and then transported into the ocean will
lead the hypoxia and many other
eutrophication problems and if nitrogen
uh go to air as
ammonium will pollute the
atom
air and even
emission as an intro will lead to
climate warming
but the people also compete for land for
living people need space to live in
there is urbanization uh everywhere
this uh
this is a line night you can see u.s
china
globally uh european uh everywhere
but if you look at the north korea
versus south korea north korea don't
have
too many uh night light but south korea
is
everywhere
like
lights so they
reflect the uh urbanization
the question here is what uh to what
extent have human activity affect net
balance of greenhouse gas in the land
biosphere
so we developed the approach integral
system report linking
field
measurement with modeling
so the different kind of field
measurement like ecosystem uh experiment
uh a difference of uh
measurement and cellular data and
atmosphere um
this like commodore oxide the
measurement
the
e model and the data that interaction
likewise use the data to
calibrate the model and also use the
given set of the data to validate the
model they
use this environmental java
climate
land use and other
atmospheric chemistry to draw this
model that can simulate to have the
output that sentences
then we in for the
last
20 years we developed a model called
dynamically landing ecosystem model
which is one of the major models today
used by
global
carbon
budget assessment and rpcc
so that
we have different components
but
physical component planetary physiology
component solved by chemicals to
component the dynamic of gt components
and also consider
disturbance like fine uh hurricane land
use and management
and this
model that one few models can
simultaneously
simulate the swinney magic greenhouse
gas like co2 medicine and natural
officer together
and very detailed
this
process involves
carbon nitrogen fossil coupling so
major green cause carbon
surface water groundwater company
so i will not
talk details so if you're interested we
can
communicate later
then we also
developed a different kind of the data
the multiscale data and around the
different
time scheme like one kilometer
resolution
five minutes and
one quarter resolution for the
continental level and also global level
and also work on the different time
steps like daily monsoon to even
millennial time step
uh and they we deconstruct a land use
history here the two of the example we
developed this land use
five-minute revolutionary
history data for india
and
china
and for many people probably don't
really introduce the detail of the model
but the interest output of the model so
the model can offer like a carbon
available and a flux system like gpp mpp
and there's net corn storage
methane buc dlc
deals in and
also the water vapor and the major
nitrogen gas and the storage and also
club crabby and wood timber bags
so we
next i give you example we
work on the
china which we use china as a
example turner's more like
natural laboratory in the past turn
40 started from a little open
opening up
there everywhere is a disturbance by in
different environment variable you can
see a kilometer
changing just like globally different
region and air pollution
the land use and coverage and nitrogen
import and natural deposition
so if you uh went to china you can see
that if people said if you stay the
hotel in the morning uh you you in the
morning you go out to visit and they
come back
even you go back to hotel you you cannot
recognize it
they look at that which means anywhere
has a building and the road developed
what do you see there at the corner of
uh
left the economy is changing everywhere
in this ten year period and the nitro
deposition largely increasing the
southern part of china and the air
pollution everywhere and particularly
bad in the
northern on the northwest
so we usually they different kind of
model and
to do this analysis attribute
that different factor contributed to
china
land cover sync
so we estimate the contribution from co2
say
climate also pollution natural
deposition not just fertilizer use
land uh management online coverage
engine uh they include like
other education as well so we found
china for the time period only uh zero
point
uh
two one pedogram carbon so that's
even the earliest day time period but
much smaller than what
we
the china 1.1 paragon carbon that time
they had
more than 60 of the contributed from a
nitrogen import
but a nitrogen main saturation
so our
status center even nitrogen increases
continually imported increased energy
temperature increase
but
the
ecosystem
carbon storage
in by middle of the 1980s reached to the
peak so the level of talent and
naturally increasing the increased cover
sun
shorter natural saturation
then with the houses uh
co2 and in uh as i said we uh the model
have capacity to aspirin methane and and
through itself two together that will
estimate three gas together and
use the
100
100 year
time horizon gwp to calculate the
greenhouse gas potential
that china
most of the uh commerce think uh
eighty-five percent that is the offset
by methane and and two
then we uh
do the similar work in the u.s if we
consider uh north american sweet as to
guess
we found 75 percent were traditional
co2 thinking that offset by
nothing and and so on uh so
that's which indicated that
uh when really important to consider
three guys together
inspired by this china and north
american study we uh
uh a couple years ago we uh to try use
both brought up and top-down approach
uh they include different different
atomos inversion system and also
different
landing system models became the two-way
constraint
and we surprised to find
the biosphere terrestrial biosphere as a
net source of greenhouse gases to the
atmosphere
so most
people that believe this
biosphere is a cooling factor
applicative covered up with for the
10-year period
the
co2 thinking bypass feeds about 1.6
paragraph carbon
so that's important for the cooling
factor
but the bus will also emit i think
and two and
ch4
so if we consider all this streak as
together
the cumulative warming capacity of
methane and nitrite oxide emission is a
affect about two
larger than the cooling factor without
from global land cell to update
so that's the
the really means
uh
biosphere
uh
it's we need a wig out but the biosphere
not really is a cooling uh place or a
cooling factory thing actually
temporary time period the bioskins
that contributed global warming
but
if we further look at this issue
the agriculture
is the largest contributor to the
netherlands greenhouse gas emissions
so agriculture alone they include
collaborating the livestocking and with
western
so the agriculture around this already
offset the palestinian carbon sink
so that's a very important
application how to best and manage
agriculture uh or uh
there will be critical for the meeting
and the climate change
then we
recognize that it's a very important to
put all the different effort into uh
this food budget for a country of the
greenhouse gas that way
and to sail to massive together and not
only global but also moved to uh
regional so this is a global carbon
party a new initiative so the currently
called regional carbon uh recap
two uh region
then with one of the efforts that i uh
co-leading with
ronna thompson
to do this
global and true budget
this is a
jointly sponsored by a global common
project and the international national
initiative
then we use a different approach to top
down bottom up
inventory and consider land ocean
river and
human society together
we
give this most appetite comprehensive
assessment global and to budget
this paper published
last year
again
say agriculture included direct soil
emission and interactive emission uh the
emissions about 70 percent total
isogenic image so agriculture play the
critical in
contributing the global entry budget
then agriculture is a
key sector for climate mitigation as i
already discussed
uh largely portion of the
methane and the natural oxide
emitted
from the aquaculture sector
of course i've gotten also
stockholm
so the soil carbon increase or product
carbon uh increase
so if we reduce
uh ch4 and two emission and the increase
of soil carbon agriculture could have
playing very critical for the kilometer
uh medication
then at the math thing
as a another airflow
the gcp leader
about
more than half of us this method mission
is a from agriculture
and this includes a livestocking
emission that we
developed this dataset set
from
1819 to
more recently
this is one kind of middle resolution
data attributed different
kind of
animal
and contributed to the mastering image
and we also
qualify a master mission from
the rust padding
and
we
we found
this
if we can better
manage the water
like in the media
water irrigation could reduce
methane emission
half of the methane issue from last
party
and we also identified the
uh
regionally the sauna asian region is a
really
critical region
for
this
extreme major greenhouse gas er
deduction so
southern asia includes
south east asia east asia south asia and
west asia will be very critical for
global
and
this
greenhouse gas reduction and medication
and we further look at the as
opportunity uh antonio mission or again
uh the east asians largely increase and
uh
south asia also largely
also very surprised afflicted
uh by playing very important law
increasingly uh largely increasingly
this
mainly from lobster talking emission
also my new emission
and the north american uh
the keeper slightly increased by
european they use the medication
strategy to properly
europeans are one of the region
there and two emissions decrease
so what is the policy implication for
the uh
this study from this study
so they
the first thing we think it it's very
important application uh greenhouse gas
emissions particularly
uh methane and tree mission
they will really help climate change
but that's done to me
we don't
want to increase carbon storage we also
want to increase soil carbon storage in
aquaculture
and also
implies this
to include three major greenhouse gas in
the global and regional climate impact
assessment
mitigation operation
climate policy development is very
important
we also should aware of
liking counter value this
impact mitigation effort lacking
when
large ethanol
try to increase sodium carbonation but
maybe
soil comes from increasing increase
could lead to inflammation increase
so increasing 2 and
n2 emission if we were pretty uh trying
to reduce into a stage 4 image
and also
peterlam fast separation
or rewarding uh they
actually uses
co2 and two emissions this could
could
change the other gases that
have also like
increased indirect emission from a few
production
so uh particularly today we
try to implement the different kind of
we call climate scenario smarter
culture practices we need
really need to consider sea gas together
to give the
full package whole picture about this
land management proactives potential
impact on stream gas
and we thinking uh adaptation of
commerce modern management parameters
is a very critical this potentially
could reverse the biosphere current and
warming effect and also we're thinking
how we're managing
global line that need to become central
part of
our strategy mitigated climate change
i think um this is my main talk but i'm
not sure what time
more time i have i have i feel so i want
to talk a little bit
uh
about uh
potentially after how uh
we can
can we adapt to and admittedly economic
change uh through pattern land
management i will uh
talk a little bit uh my group effort uh
so if you are interesting we can talk in
more
uh detail uh in uh strong
uh
rest of the day and also maybe
eventually we can schedule another time
to
talk
so one of the effort we
developed a tune
for
climate smart agriculture
to incorporate a detailed management
scheme
into this dynamic and ecosystem model
then we applied to different region uh
here show this
africa
so we are also
[Music]
another important uh
livestocking production crime smarter
love the stock production this publisher
a wonderful few models able to
assimilate the animal dynamic uh include
person death and migration
so we
the last i will end my talking with one
example uh that we funding by nsf the
infield project would compare a yellow
river basin at the mississippi with
river basin both the agricultural
intensive region
that's uh
the region
and we
calibrated this model used
about 214 of the visuals experimented
across different parts of the u.s mostly
located in the
midwest
then
look compared the foa data and also the
u.s agriculture data and the model that
the result looks quite commense
and we simulated
the three major
call
the club and the core
soybean and winter
wheat across the u.s and compared to
the
usda
data that's quite consistent
uh that way
as i said that we
say we try to
pursue crop yield uh not only pressure
crop here but we also want the minimized
greenhouse gas emission so we
to maximum crop year and minimize the
greenhouse gas emissions so
and
another example that we manage
nitrogen fertilizer
like here that we internal region we uh
nitro fertilizers continually increase
the
soil carbon to increase and the yield
also doesn't increase but
and
to increase largely about the 2000
early 2000s this in tune this
red color is already surpassed
the co2 uptake so that uh largely input
the leader to warming effect so we have
early paper said that carter turner uh
nigel used half of the energy use could
hear the climate
and the way further to do this uh
experiment reduce sensitivity analysis
reducing
nitrogenous twenty percent forty percent
sixty percent the crop yet it doesn't
change too much
soil carbon uh
also
doesn't change too much
but
there's a nitrogen lesion
uh
largely
decreases the n2o emissions largely give
us about
reducer 50 percent so
let's
inform the theatre
opposition relation of the other
scientists
and the farmer
reducing large fertilizers could
increase
could
reduce the uh and to imagine help the
calamita also created this nitrogen
loading into the water that reduces this
water pollution but not
if managing properly will not affect the
crop year and the soil cover
so we haven't success
in answering all problems
the problem we have funded only to list
a whole set of new questions in some way
we feel we are as confused as ever but
we believe
we are confused on a high level and
about the more important thing
uh
since we have a new uni
uh
there's effort call in my platoon global
nitrogen until
uh model in the comparison project face
tune so i'm the leader this
uh ever under the
global carbohydrate international
nutrient project so before
any of you interesting could continue
we can together make the world better
so
thank you for your
attention this is my
today's talk
if you have any question i would be
happy to take it
thank you very much dr dan for your
great
representation
uh
any questions from the room
okay i have a question dr tian i would
like to hear more of your thoughts about
your like the
uh
the uh your insights about the
comparison between the chinese china and
the u.s the yellow river basin and
mississippi reason what you you inside
generated from another
infused project
yeah
this ongoing project
we
um major difference the yellow river and
the mississippi river basin and the
yellow river really is water limited uh
this serious problem yeah the water but
also
in that
upper
uh
stream they have a lot of stem and
there's uh
uh hydropower is the bigger issue and
also they use the water in there for
this coal uh energy uh
that says what polluted the water and
fertilizing also the bigger issue
so
yellow
river as
both the water quality and quantities of
serious problem
so we
but the water
quantity even worse don't have water
but then mississippi river basin we uh
we
of course the water is the issue
but the
most
serious problem is a water quality form
so the large
number of the nitrogen loading into
the river and
exported to golf
that's like your nitrogen eutrophication
and
hypothermia is a really big challenge
so we also have the energy issue with
the powerful energy
so the issue the project that we really
try to link
for the world energy together
great thank you so much a question from
ed
uh so ed also posted his question in the
chat window i do want to speak correctly
sure yeah i was just wondering in your
one figure you were showing that natural
first of all a wonderful talk really
enjoyed uh the research
uh but you had a your natural land area
had more nitrous oxide coming off in
agriculture today what are some of those
big natural sources of nitrous oxide
uh
i'm not very sure the number natural
anti-emission the great agriculture how
i need a double check system uh but the
natural emissions are very large uh the
particular
in the uh sauce
uh sodden part of
the like tropical all the southeastern
their warm climate and their soil
and naturally mission very high
but let me
show this again um
okay
would you which slide you talk about
uh well i was looking at it from i think
it's your uh
you know
2016 paper and you have uh
i just pulled it up here
it uh
it has your natural soil
as essentially 7.5 uh tons coming from
natural soil and 4.4 from agriculture
for nitrous oxide and oh yeah that is
this slide 38
was this one yeah
okay so i was comparing
the nitrous oxide one
and i was i guess there was a little
surprise that natural soil was 7.5 was
larger than agriculture
yeah
uh if we consider um if we consider
natural soil natural soil emission
then
this uh
agriculture probably only about uh fifty
percent of the gallery image uh so
that's the previous uh like ipcc uh and
uh fyao
add
fcc they don't
consider natural emission
so this
this study is considered both the
natural emission and as for genetic
english together
so that
so
that's the
one of the argument is that what it
means as a foreign emission people
thinking
like a climate warming is caused by
people caused by esophagenic so they
think economic changes should be part of
anthropogenic so have some
debate
but natural soil emissions very large
thank you
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu